in the Great Basin National Park are
some of the oldest living organisms in
the world they have been there since you
were born
and since Caesar was born they were
there for the Roman the Greek the
Egyptian empires and they have been
standing at the top of that mountain
quietly growing for over 5,000 years
it's incredibly subjective a human
lifespan is a hundred years Empire can
rise and fall within a thousand against
a geological time scale we're all just
tiny sparks of life but some organisms
glow for a little bit longer here in the
Great Basin National Park are the
Bristlecone Pines one of these beautiful
ancient gnarled trees that was born
today could live to see us leave the
planet and go to other stars it might
see us change fundamentally as humans or
even disappear altogether where I'm
sitting the Bristlecone pines are way
way back there down at this lower
elevation Bristlecone pines look like
normal pine trees you wouldn't know them
as anything special if you went by them
but that just shows their adaptability
because as they go up the mountain they
turn into something else they they stay
small they become these gnarled smooth
little 6-foot tall creatures they use
their resources very very slowly we
didn't always know how old Bristlecone
trees were in the past people had
associated the size of trees with their
age in 1964 a graduate student and
geographer named donald curie
found the world's oldest living organism
a tree named the prometheus tree that
turned out to be at least 49 hundred
years old and probably over 5000 there
was just one small problem which is that
in finding out its age he also killed it
people were not happy about this it was
kind of kept quiet for a few years but
when it came out people were furious
exactly what happened is a little
unclear it's possible that Donald
Curry's boring tool got stuck in the
tree and then the Park Service offered
to cut the tree down to help him get his
tool back
or they maybe cut it down so they could
get a thin slice of it and really know
how old it was wasn't until they killed
it and started counting its rings they
realized that they had killed the
world's oldest living thing it was a
bummer but here's where I elect Alec Rio
he wanted to understand how the world
had changed by looking at both living
and dead Bristlecone Pines it was a
window into 10,000 years of history
changing the way we think about time not
in quarters or presidential cycles or
even human lifespans
but in thousands of years is
increasingly important thinking about
something that has been living for 5,000
years that was alive it as a singular
thing as a singular organism was they
are growing before the invention of the
alphabet before the invention of musical
notation before they mentioned the sword
it changes your very perspective on time
itself other trees have since been found
which have been dated to be older they
were not killed in the dating process
and they've also been kept secret their
locations have been hidden they don't
even really have names because they are
meant to stay anonymous but as the world
warms the Bristlecone pine has been
moving ever higher in search of cooler
climates and one day they're gonna run
out of space they'll be at the top of
the mountains and there'll be nowhere
left for them to go and then after 5,000
years of quiet living the Bristlecone
Pines will be at a time subscribe here
and watch more videos here if you come
to the Great Basin National Park in the
summer you can hike up to a grove of
Bristlecone pines you can even see the
stump of Prometheus it's just an
incredibly beautiful place to visit